.
BRET?
>> Bret: DAVID LEE MILLER IN NEW
YORK.
DAVID, THANKS.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL EARLY.
FORMER EDUCATION SECRETARY BILL
BENNETT, HAROLD FORD JR. FORMER
TENNESSEE CONGRESSMAN CEO OF
EMPOWERMENT INCLUSION CAPITAL
AND BYRON YORK.
BILL, FOR SOME, IT FELT LIKE
THIS WAS A LONG TIME AND IT
DRAGGED ON.
IF YOU LOOK AT KIND OF HOW
THINGS EVOLVED, HOW DO YOU SEE
THIS RESIGNATION TODAY THAT
COMES 14 DAYS FROM NOW?
>> WELL, IT'S OVER.
AND I THINK THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS
GRATEFUL THAT IT'S OVER.
REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS,
EVERYBODY.
LISTENING TO THE IS A LITTLE FOE
GET OUT AND IT'S TIME THAT HE
DID.
I'M GLAD THAT HE DID.
NOW THERE MAY BE THESE TRIALS.
I HOPE PEOPLE CAN FOCUS ON WHAT
SEEM TO ME THE MOST IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS OF LAW, WHICH IS THE
LIABILITY OF ANDREW CUOMO IF
CRIMINAL OR CIVIL OF THESE
NURSING HOMES.
THE DEATHS OF PEOPLE IN THESE
LET THAT NOT BE FORGOTTEN, AND
LET'S CARRY FORWARD ON THAT.
BUT I'M GLAD THIS CHAPTER IS
OVER.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
LESSONS HERE, TOO.
AND A MAJOR ONE FOR THE MEDIA.
I DON'T WANT TO OCCUPY ALL THE
TIME.
>> Bret: YEAH.
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE NURSING
HOMES, THE LAWMAKER WHO WAS
SPEARHEADING THAT, RON KIM, A
DEMOCRAT, WEIGHED IN ON THIS
RESIGNATION TODAY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>>
>> I'M RELIEVED THAT HE STEPPED
DOWN SO WE CAN FOCUS ON THE
PEOPLE'S WORK.
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL FOR THE WOMEN
WHO STEPPED UP COURAGEOUSLY.
I HAVE COMMITTED BACK IN MARTHA
AFTER HE DEPOSE DOWN FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT I WILL
STILL BE HERE TO HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE THOUSANDS OF
NURSING HOME DEATHS THAT
HAPPENED UNDER HIS WATCH.
>> Bret: BYRON, IN THE BIG
PEOPLE PEOPLE SAID THAT WAS SO
MUCH MORE EGREGIOUS NOT IN THE
SCALE OF HOW THINGS ARE BAD BUT
AS FAR AS THE IMPACT ON FAMILIES
ACROSS NEW YORK.
>> WELL, WHAT WAS CLEAR IS THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S REPORT
KILLED HIM.
HE JUST COULD NOT SURVIVE IT.
ANY DEMOCRAT WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN
INCLINED TO SUPPORT HIM FELL
AWAY AFTER THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REPORT.
AND THE REASON HE RESIGNED TODAY
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE WHOLE
COVID NURSING HOME THING, IT WAS
BECAUSE HE SAW THAT AFTER THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S REPORT HE DID
NOT HAVE THE MINIMUM LEVEL OF
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO STAY IN
OFFICE.
AND TODAY WAS VERY STRATEGIC.
HIS EVENT WAS VERY STRATEGIC.
IT GAM BEGAN WITH HIS LAWYER
GOING ON FOR NEARLY AN HOUR
ATTACKING THAT REPORT.
NEARLY LINE BY LINE.
QUESTIONING THE CREDIBILITY OF
ALL OF THE ALLEGATIONS.
AND THEN THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF
CAME OUT AND, AGAIN, ATTACKED
THE REPORT QUESTIONING ITS
CREDIBILITY.
AND HE ADMITTED TO SMALL THINGS.
HE SAID WELL, YOU KNOW, MY SENSE
OF HUMOR CAN OFFEND PEOPLE
SOMETIMES.
AND MAYBE I'M AN OLD THROWINGY
AND I HAVEN'T REALIZED HOW THE
RULES FOR INTERACTIONS BETWEEN
MEN AND WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE
HAVE CHANGED.
BUT HE WAS CLEAR TO SAY THAT HE
DID NOTHING WRONG.
AND THIS IS REALLY FOR A COUPLE
OF REASONS.
HE STILL MIGHT FACE CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
HE COULDN'T VERY WELCOME OUT
TODAY AND ADMIT IT.
SO HE DENIED EVERYTHING IN TERMS
OF ANY POTENTIAL CHARGES AGAINST
HIM.
AND THE OTHER THING IS HE IS 63
YEARS OLD.
HE THINKS MAYBE IN A FEW YEARS
THINGS COULD CHANGE, CONDITIONS
COULD CHANGE, SOMETHING
UNEXPECTED COULD HAPPEN AND HE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO RUN FOR OFFICE
AGAIN.
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS RESIGNATION
TODAY WAS ABOUT.
>> Bret: WHICH IS TRULY AMAZING
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE MEDIA
COVERAGE OF THIS GOVERNOR
LIFTING HIM UP IN COVID, THE
REALLY VAUNTED STATUS, SOME
PEOPLE WANTED HIM TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
THEN THEY WERE NAMING HIM,
HAROLD, AS A VICE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
TODAY, IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
RESIGNATION SPEECH ON ANOTHER
CHANNEL, THERE WAS THIS AS BY
RON JUST MENTIONED A CUOMO
COMEBACK.
>> WE KNOW OUR WORLD WORKS IT'S
AMAZING, THE PEOPLE WE HAVE SEEN
MAKE POLITICAL COMEBACKS.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T EVER RULE IT
OUT.
HE EVENTUALLY DID SOMETHING THAT
WAS -- THAT MAYBE OVER TIME WILL
AT LEAST GIVE HIM AN OPENING TO,
OH, MAYBE, YOU KNOW, NOT BE A
FULL PARIAH IN THE PARTY SAY IN
THREE YEARS, FOUR YEARS, FIVE
YEARS.
I EXPECT IN MY LIFETIME ANDREW
CUOMO TO PROBABLY RUN FOR OFFICE
AGAIN.
WHAT THAT OFFICE IS, I DON'T
KNOW.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THIS RESIGNATION
TELLS ME TODAY.
>> Bret: IF WE WAIT LIKE ONE
HOUR, MAYBE TWO HOURS BEFORE THE
CUOMO COMEBACK ANALYSIS, HAROLD?
>> LOOK, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE KIND OF
ANALYSIS WHO KNOWS I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS FOR HIM OR FOR ANY
POLITICIAN.
I DO KNOW THIS THOUGH.
IT WAS DEMOCRATS NATIONALLY AND
STATE AND LOCAL NEW YORK
DEMOCRATS THAT EVENTUALLY
BROUGHT AN END TO HIS
GOVERNORSHIP RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE GOING TO BE THOSE WHO
QUARREL WITH HIS RESIGNATION
SPEECH.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE
RESIGNED.
IT ALLOWS THE STATE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
IT ALLOWS THE NEW LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR TO TAKE OVER AND MANAGE
THE RECOVERY, THE SURGE, THE
COVID-19 SURGE AND TACKLE THE
CRIME AND RESTORE PUBLIC SAFETY
ACROSS THE STATE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE,
DEMOCRATS HELD HIM TO THE SAME
STANDARD THAT THEY HAVE HELD
OTHERS AROUND THESE ISSUES.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT
WAS THE PRESIDENT, THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE, AND WASHINGTON,
THE SPEAKER OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY OF NEW YORK, THE
SENATORS AND A WHOLE HOST OF
DEMOCRATS THAT SAID ENOUGH WAS
ENOUGH.
>> Bret: HERE IS JUST A REVIEW,
KIND OF A MONTAGE TO LISTEN TO.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I NEVER TOUCHED ANYONE
INAPPROPRIATELY.
>> THE INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION
FOUND THAT GOVERNOR CUOMO
SEXUALLY HARASSED MULTIPLE
WOMEN.
>> SOME SUFFERED THROUGH
UNWANTED TOUCHING AND GRABBING
OF THEIR MOST INTIMATE BODY
PARTS.
>> THE GOVERNOR HUGGED EXECUTIVE
ASSISTANT NUMBER ONE AND REACHED
UNDER HER BLOUSE TO GRAB HER
BREAST.
>> I KNOW THE TRUTH.
HE KNOWS THE TRUTH.
I KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
AND SO DOES HE.
>> THE BEST WAY I CAN HELP NOW
IS IF I STEP ASIDE AND LET
GOVERNMENT GET BACK TO
GOVERNING.
AND, THEREFORE, THAT'S WHAT I'LL
DO.
>> Bret: LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
KATHY HOKLE TAKES OVER IN 14
DAYS THE GOVERNOR'S MANSION.
NOT CLEAR HER INFLUENCE IN
ALBANY OR HOW THAT WILL ALL
TRANSPIRE.
ANY THOUGHTS ON THE FIRST FEMALE
GOVERNOR ACTUALLY IN NEW YORK
TAKING THE REINS?
>> I KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT HER.
I WANT TO SAY POINT ABOUT THE
MEDIA.
BECAUSE OF THE OUTSIZED PRESENCE
OF THE MEDIA IN NEW YORK, WE
WERE SATURATED WITH THIS
COVERAGE.
AND, YOU KNOW, MANY MORE
IMPORTANT ISSUES ARE GOING ON IN
THIS COUNTRY THE INVASION OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, CRIME,
RESOLUTION OF THE SCHOOLS.
BRET, I THINK YOU OUGHT TO
SUGGEST SOME OF THE MAINLY MEDIA
MIGHT WANT TO MOVE TO FLORIDA OR
SOME OTHER STATE.
THIS WOULD BE GOOD IN TERMS OF
DIFFERENTIATING A LITTLE BIT.
WE KNOW IT'S AN ECHO CHAMBER CBS
HAS LUNCH WITH NBC AND THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
I DON'T THINK THE GOVERNOR OF
TENNESSEE WHERE HAROLD IS FROM
OR THE GOVERNOR OF NORTH
CAROLINA WHERE I'M SITTING MADE
THESE PRONOUNCEMENTS WOULD HAVE
HAD NEARLY THE AFFECTS.
THIS IS PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE
INCREDIBLE I OBJECT INFLUENCE.
NEW YORK, WASHINGTON AND L.A.
DISPROPORTIONATE.
>> ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND HER
PROSPECTS AND DEALING WITH
ALBANY WHICH CAN BE A TOUGH
PLACE TO MAKE THINGS HAPPEN?
>> BRET, ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?
>> Bret: YEAH.
>> I'M SORRY.
YOU BROKE UP ONE SECOND.
I THINK SHE WILL HAVE HER
HANDFUL.
SHE APPARENTLY IS REACHING OUT
TO SOME OF THE CURRENT AIDES
THAT MAY WANT TO STAY ON.
SHE HAS HER OWN TEAM.
SHE HAS SERVED IN CONGRESS SO
SHE BELIEVES RELATIONSHIPS WITH
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
AS MUCH AS HER HAND WILL BE FULL
BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENING TO
QUICKLY.
I THINK SHE IS GOING TO MOVE
INTO THIS POSITION WITH
EXPERIENCE, WITH THE EXPERTISE
AND WITH THE RELATIONSHIPS TO DO
WELL.
THE KEY WILL BE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE NEW NEW
YORK CITY MAYOR WHICH LIKELY
WILL BE ERIC ADAMS.
>> Bret: OKAY.